ah so hello and welcome to another
episode of biographics I'm your host KL
Smallwood yes that is my real name and
today we're talking about Chuck Berry
the father of rock and roll and I do own
a guitar and I did think about doing a
joke of bringing a guitar out and
playing wonder wall but then I realized
that I'd just be doing that awkward
annoying dude thing of playing wonder
wall when no one asked to a mass
audience a captive audience should I say
not that you're captive you can click
off anytime you want but please don't so
instead I brought the first album I ever
bought and we'll just invite people in
the comments to tell us the first album
you bought mine is Dragon forces inhuman
Rampage because I was a nerd also this
video is based on original article
submitted by Ru Alexander links to their
socials can be found
below when the Rock and Roll Hall of
Fame first opened in 1986 chuckberry was
the first induct te that's all that
really needs to be said isn't it but we
have some more if you want there are of
course the standard accolades one of the
best guitarists of all time one of the
best musicians of all time one of the
founders of rock and roll etc etc but
chuckberry can boast one unique honor no
other rock and roll star can yes even
Dolly P that his music will be the only
one heard by aliens so back in 1977 when
NASA launched the Voyager 1 and 2 space
probes into deep space they included two
copies of the so-called golden record
that contained a collection of sites and
sounds of life on Earth therefore if
thousands potentially millions of years
from now an intelligent alien species
would find the probe the golden record
would act as a sort of Time Capsule of
humanity showcasing our best and
greatest among other things the record
includes a diverse 90minut selection of
Music carefully curated by a committee
led by Carl San to showcase the best
that human culture had to offer only one
rock and roll song made the cut chuck
Beres Johnny Be Good which is just
awesome I like the idea of like alien
getting that then coming to Earth and
like okay so you got any more songs his
Chuck Berry dude he's pretty awesome oh
he's
dead Chu Barry was born Charles Edward
Anderson Berry on October 18th 1926 in
St Louis Missouri the fourth of six
children of Henley William Berry and
Martha Bell both of his parents were
descended from Slavs and they left the
South okay to Missouri between World War
I to seek out better opportunities one
could say they found them compared to
how many other black families were still
being treated in the United States
chuckberry andjoy made a decidedly
middle class upbringing his father had a
good job at a flower Mill also work as a
carpenter on weekends and has served as
la la preacher of the local Baptist
Church and a superintendent for the
Sunday School meanwhile his mother was
one of the few black women in a city who
had earned a college degree the Barry
family lived in a neighborhood in North
St Louis known as The Ville it was a
middle class respectable black community
where businesses and institutions could
not just survive but Thrive still let's
not pretend it was all Sunshine and
Lollipops St Louis was still heavily
segregated and was so segregated in fact
that ch Barry was 3 years old when he
saw his first white person when some
firemen came to his neighborhood to put
out a fire Barry recalled that at the
time he thought the men's face that
turned white from fear and his father
put him straight telling him and I quote
they were white people and their skin
was always white that way day or night
very poetic one both the Barry's parents
sang in the church choir and even
rehearsed at home with the entire choir
gathered around the piano in the front
room as Barry would later record his
earliest memories were of music and it
quickly became a dominating presence in
his life the family moved the house a
few times times as it got bigger and
bigger there were some lean years though
during the Great Depression as work at
the Mill became scarce so Henry Barry
found a new job selling vegetables door
to door and as a contractor for a realy
company Chuck and his older siblings
started to pitch in with the word to the
point where they almost became full-time
jobs and their father even paid them a
nominal wage during all this time
Barry's passion for music kept
blossoming and he had met a local jazz
musician named IRA Harris who gave him
guitar lessons and already he began to
develop his signature style he gave his
first stage performance while he was
still in high school during a student
show where he played confessing the
Blues by J McShan The Faculty weren't
too pleased with this and consider the
song a bit too unruly and inappropriate
for the children but the children
themselves went absolutely bananas and
Barry knew then and there he was born to
be an Entertainer I'm also seeing like
you know shades of the um bat of the
Future movie where m f do the same thing
with one of his songs from there he
started performing at Uso dancers for
black soldiers during the war however he
did this mainly to meet girls is there
any other reason men learn to play
guitar he never really considered it a
viable job and as far as his Budd
musical career was concerned it came to
a screeching halt following One Summer
of Madness for most of his teenage years
Barry engaged in Petty balance of crime
the worst thing he did was Cipher some
gas from parked trucks but then in the
summer of 1944 he left on an ill judge
road trip in his timobile with two
friends Skip and James their dream was
to make it to California but they' never
even left the state for whatever reason
Chu decided to bring along a busted up
pistol he found in a parking lot it
didn't work someone even tried to burn
it and all that was left was a barrel
and a few of the bits and pieces of
course others wouldn't know this and
from a distance it looked perfectly
lethal so on their way to Kansas City
Missouri the trio decided to just start
robbing people as you do first they
targeted a bakery and made off with a
princely su of $62 a lot of money at a
time the following day they entered
Kansas City self and robbed a barber
shop and a clothing store making off
with another $80 and some shirts they
didn't really have the makings of Public
Enemies number one anyway by that point
Barry's oldmobile was already starting
to crap out on them so they decided that
their grand tour had come to an end
turned around and began driving back
home but before they got there they
decided they should pull off one final
stick up when their car clunked out
permanently on the side of the road
their victim Was a Good Samaritan
driving a Chevy who stopped to help and
his car Got Hijacked for its troubles
but this is where the three criminal
masterminds came up with a really
moronic plan instead of Simply driving
the Chevy back home they wanted to use
it to push the oldmobile all the way to
St Louis with one of them driving the
Chevy and Barry steering his old rust
bucket unsurprisingly the owner of the
Chevy alert the authorities and state
troopers didn't find it too difficult to
locate the two vehicles slowly plodding
along the road the trio of criminals
might as well have mounted a sign that
said come and arrest Us in giant neon
lights and just like that Chu Berry
found himself in Boon County Jail in
Columbia Missouri Henry Berry paid $125
for a lawyer to defend all three boys
but they pled guilty on his advice and
got on the maximum sentence of 10 years
Barry was sent to the intermediate
reform for young man near Jefferson City
where he will spend the next 3 years of
his
life so I never knew this it's like
we're going to rob a guy we're going to
steal his car then we're going to use
his stolen car to push our crap car all
the way home this plan is Flawless and
that's the plan of a teenager life in
prison was no picnic which is sort of an
obvious statement but Barry tried to
make it as comfortable as possible he
befriended his guard who was a literate
by reading and writing letters for him
brry also had the idea to put together a
vocal quartet for black prisoners and
their group was so well received that
they actually got to start performing
for white Services as well furthermore a
noname sister felma even got them a few
gigs outside the prison playing at a
church in St Louis H when he wasn't
singing Buri to got boxing even competed
in a Golden Gloves tournament which
again afford him a brief moment of
Freedom outside the cold Prison Walls
but he got thoroughly walloped in the
final and put an end to his pugilistic
career on October 18th 1947 on the day
of his 21st birthday chuckberry got
paralled he was given $69 for the work
he did in prison and a train to get to
St Louis later that afternoon he was
back home and looking to make up for
lost time just a few months later he met
and fell in love with the meta sus who
he nicknamed toddy the couple got
married a year later after Barry's
released from prison they would stay
married for almost 70 years and have
four children together to support his
new family Barry started working various
odd jobs janitor caretaker renovator as
well as going back to work at his dad's
carpentry business he also took on a
small gig as a musician since this was
still his true passion and ambition
fairly quickly he began developing his
own style by taking the blues and and
gospel music he'd grown up with and
mixing it with a bit of country to give
it a broader appeal to White audiences
some people started referring to Barry
as the black hillbilly but they danced
through music all the same black
audiences didn't shy away from his style
and he began attracting white crowds as
well at the end of the day both groups
just wented to groove to some good old
fashioned rock and roll which didn't
exist yet but it was about to chunkberry
was officially on the up and up in the
St Louis music scene he began playing
various clubs across town sometimes
going by Chu baring instead of Barry in
a halfast attempt to distance his
father's respectful and reverent name
from the wild world of popular music
Barry invested some of the money he made
during his musical career by buying his
first electric guitar and a real tooreal
magnetic recorder so he could start
working on his own ideas now that he was
somewhat of an name Barry began meeting
some of his own musical Heroes such as
Muddy Waters who introduced him to
Lenard chess the head of the Chicago
base Chess Records normally Chess
Records was seen as a small but serious
Blues label but Leonard Chess was more
interested in Barry's new Blues Country
Fusion style specifically in Barry's own
version of the traditional song Ida Red
they decided to record something new
adapting parts from older songs and
fitting it into Barry's new style the
result Changed music forever it was
called
Maybelline in July 1955 chuckberry
released mayine a word I've said more in
the last 5 minutes than I have in my
entire life it was an immediate hit with
both black and white audiences and ended
up selling over a million records and
Topping the billboard rhythm and blues
charts today that song is regarded as
the unequivocal Cornerstone of that hip
new theme the kids call rock and roll as
Rolling Stone want to put it rock and
roll starts here unsurprisingly this
turned CH Berry into one of the biggest
rising stars in the country but he soon
discovered there were more things to
know about the music business than how
to make a hit record when he first
received a copy of Maybelline he was
surprised to see that two other people
had writing credits for the song even
though neither one had anything to do
with it one was DJ Allan freed whose
career was later destroyed by the
so-called Peola Scandal of the early 60s
as it turned out freed had been taking
bries for years years in exchange for
increased air time for certain songs to
raise their popularity most times he
took cold hard cash but when dealing
with smaller labels like Chess Records
you would also accept a writing credit
and this is just one of those things in
the music industry that you just the
more you learn about it the more you
realize it's completely full there is a
term that I have become familiar with
thanks to the documentary I think it's
like called pop or something like that
it's called write a word get a third and
in a nutshell um what you do is you get
someone to write an actual song then the
pop star that you wrote it before comes
in and you get them to suggest a change
any change even so much a word and as
soon as they do that they get a writing
credit because technically they help
write the song and there is an amazing
part of that documentary where they're
talking to a metal musician of all
things who wrote pinks so what and he
says that he came up with the iconic
Riff to that like
the came with that on the Spot while was
like you know noodling around in a
guitar and he talk it's it's it's so
it's so amazingly edited says well I
wrote that you know basically the basis
of the song but then pink came in and
wrote the lyrics which if people recall
is na na na na na na na na na na na na
in time with the the Riff that he wrote
It's fascinating anyway one of the other
alleged writers was a businessman named
Russ fratto who supplied chess records
with stationary and the like it's a
little weird to see a printer and a
stationer named as one of the writers
for one of the most popular rock and
roll songs of all time but this was
probably done to cover a payment that
Leonard Chess owed him after all by
paying in with writing credit it wasn't
Chess Records that was foot in the bill
instead the money will be coming out of
Barry slice of the pie it wasn't until
1986 that Chu Barry regained the soulle
writing credits for the song but it did
teach him a very important lesson about
carefully reading something before
signing it the rest of his career Barry
notoriously became one of the biggest
stickers with details in the business
who would pour over every detail and
every single word of every contract that
he signed if something happened during
an international tour that would cause
the local currency to devalue he would
insist on renegotiating his contracts
even though he would have only cost him
a few dollars that's how particular he
became but all of that was in the future
and we're still talking about 1955 and
Chu Berry had just received his first
royalty check which was for about
$20,000 more money than he made his
entire life up to that point add to that
a three-year contract with the gay
booking agency that guaranteed the
artist $40,000 a year in gigs and
chuckberry had officially turned the
corner Down Easy Street and as we all
know chuckberry was far from a one- hit
wonder and the second half of the 50s
saw a string of hits follow Maybelline
although none of them ever reached the
stratospheric levels of success in the
charts there was rooll Over Beethoven
school days and rock and roll music and
of course the iconic Johnny Be Good
Barry's recording career was extensive
to say the least as he kept writing new
music until the very end so much so that
we couldn't possibly mention it all here
his debut album after school sessions
was released in 1957 his final album
Chuck came out in 2017 the year of his
death between those two there were over
60 other Studio live and compilation
albums not to mention dozens of singles
and EPs and compilations JS and
appearing with other artists on their
tracks but despite his newf found
success Barry did not end the decade
like he wanted as once again he landed
himself in hot water with the
law in December 1959 Barry was playing a
concert in El Paso Texas before the gig
he and the band decided to kill some
time by crossing the border and hitting
some strip clubs in huarez Mexico there
Barry met a teenage girl named Janice
Escalante and according to Barry's own
autobiography he asked her her age
although she refused to say another
woman told him that Janice was 21
ostensively she was actually 14 years
old Barry brought her back with him to
St Louis and even got a job as a hat
check girl at his place Club Bandstand
whatever happened between them in that
time you can imagine on your own or go
on to Wikipedia because we don't want to
get demonetized and I don't want that
sound clip floating around on the
internet a few weeks later the police
arrived at Barry's Club wanted to
question him about Janice it wasn't her
age that anyone cared about it was that
Barry transported her across state lines
for moral purposes which is a violation
of the man act that could carry with it
a sentence to 10 years in prison this
wasn't the first time that Barry got in
trouble with the man act back in 1958 he
got pulled over while driving an
18-year-old Joe mathys from St Louis to
Toledo but the jury found him not guilty
after a favorable testimony from matis
who insisted that she was in love with
Barry there was nothing immoral about
their relationship this time though it
was alleged that Jenice escalan worked
as a prostitute back in El Paso and that
she continues to do so in St Louis
whether or not this is true we can't say
for sure but we can say the judge on the
case was an 8-year-old Relic who proudly
displayed his racism like a badge of
honor oftentimes even refusing to
address Barry by his name and instead
referring to him as and I this is a
direct quote and it really makes me feel
awkward to say but this Negro it was a a
different much more racist time
fortunately for the musician he launched
a successful appeal where the judges
ruled correctly that the blatant racism
display by the original George made the
trial unfair so Barry had escaped in
maximum sentence by the skin of his
teeth but he wasn't off the hook just
yet the trial was dismissed but the
charges against him still existed Barry
now had to wait for a new trial and he
tried to record new music in the
meantime but his head just wasn't in the
game you know prison looming overhead
tends to do that the retrial took place
in June 1961 and unfortunately for Barry
he was found guilty once again but
fortunately the sentence wasn't quite as
harsh this time just three years but his
appeal failed so in February 1962 Chuck
Barry one of the most popular artists in
the country was headed to prison for a
second time he got out in October 1963
after 20 months behind bars he was
pleasantly surprised discover that the
British Invasion of rock bands
particularly The Beatles are kept
interest in his music high so he got
right back to recording new songs he
made new hits like Nadine and you never
can tell and even went on a big tour of
the UK for the first time in his life
but still something was missing we know
it's cliche to say that prison changed
the man but in this case it really did
As Told by Kyle Perkins Barry's friend
and musical partner who accompan him on
the tour he said and I quote I'd never
seen a man so changed you'd been an
easygoing guy before the kind of guy
who' Jam in dressing rooms sit and swap
licks and jokes in England he was cold
real distant and bitter it wasn't just
jail it was those years there's one NS
grinding out like that can kill a man
but I figure it was mostly
jail the reality is that Chuck Berry
never managed to once again regain the
same level of success he had before
going to prison in 1966 he left Chess
Records after a decade with them and
signed with Mercury records Barry spent
three years with Mercury releasing Five
albums under their label however he did
not produce any hits that charted during
that time not that mercury really cared
what they were mainly interested in is
having Barry re-record all of his hits
that they could have masters of their
own Barry later regretted this move
boning that his recycled songs were not
as good as the originals look at that
what a hipster in 1970 since his
contract with Mercury was up Barry made
a return to Chess Record this will be
the last prolific decade of his career
recording six Studio albums and a few
live ones and compilations success in
the chart still remained elusive though
except for one bizarre and highly
unlikely occasion where Barry sang My
dingling My dingling I want you to play
with my dingling if those lyrics made
you giggle that's because they're
supposed to my dingling was a novelty
song ostensibly about a little boy
playing with some Bells tied to a string
accept um as it was later very
accurately described a sophomoric double
on Tundra Laden ODed to masturbation
moral campaigner and person who was
always wrong about everything Mary White
House tried to get it banned in the UK
even some of Chuck Berry's older fans
were mortified by the idea that this
this this will be the song that newer
Generations will remember him by instead
of Maybelline or Johnny Be Good and yet
somehow my dingling reached the top of
the Billboard charts becoming Chuck
Berry's only number one single and this
reminds me a little bit of a great story
about you know David Bowe who s I think
it's like the magic gnome a novelty song
by him and like the f one of the final
tours of his career he was like oh yeah
I'll I'll sing whatever songs people in
the location I'm going to want me to
sing here's a place where you can vote
and they're just like a massive online
fan campaign like Mak him sing the
little now making him sing about a magic
wizard now and David B almost did it
until he like um found out it was a
Grassroots campaign so that's not fair
you're influencing the results like damn
it sing about stupid no so the rest of
the 1970s were leaner years for Barry in
terms of new material but his oldies
were still Goldies so his concert stayed
pretty packed once again the musician
ended the decade in trouble with the law
this time for tax evasion a true
musician through and through he was
found guilty and sent back to The
Slammer except for this time it was only
for 120 days this is probably as good a
time as any to mention that Barry kept
having running into the law in the
decades that followed and although he
never served time again these included
some pretty disturbing instances
including a class action lawsuit filed
by multiple women for allegedly filming
them in the bathroom in one of his
restaurants Cas where Barry settled for
over a million dollars from the ' 80s
onwards Barry remained a main stay on
the live tour circuit although he didn't
record a new studio album till 2017
released after his death chuckberry died
on March 18th 2017 at 1990 years of age
leing behind a flawed and controversial
Legacy that often forces his fans to
separate the man from the artist
recognizing one as a person with
questionable morals to say the least and
the other one of the true pioneers of
the genre so thank you to everyone for
tuning into this episode of biographics
as mentioned at the start this video was
based on original article submitted by
Ru Alexander and I've been your co-host
co-host host Carl small you can find
links to both of our socials below if
you want to watch more of my stuff um
you can find me at fa them with K small
and Wiki weekends which has an allog
together more casual Town than this uh I
also like know once again ask people let
us know the first album you bought or
the one that informed your musical
tastes in the comments below for me it
was this one just as a kid like my dad
likes to like you know Black Sabbath and
stuff like yeah I think I like heavy
metal then I heard this and like wow
heavy metal can be rad and have 4 and a
half minute long guitar solos I want to
play guitar now and yeah and while
you're down there comment on that why
not comment on you know your favorite
part of the video or my hosting and
presentation style which I am looking
for feedback on if you like the video
leave a like and if you have you know
desire to watch more videos like this
subscribe to the channel to see more
videos like this and as always I'd like
to wish everybody watching at home a
lovely day and the day that they deserve
cheers also someone probably wondering
like what's on my t-shirt this is just
the logo for my channel and we made a
joke in a video once about what would be
like you know the most metal thing
imaginable and it' be imagine like a
chimera you like Cerberus like a billion
of them all stuck together that' be
Chimera geddon right and just a fan just
sent me a drawing of that and I went
that's a metal album cover right there
Chimera geddon
cheers